Bienvenidos en 5 minutos Perú vive uno
de sus capítulos más convulsos de su
historia moderna Pedro Castillo que fue
presidente hasta el pasado 7 de
diciembre fue destituido por el congreso
luego de que él mismo lo intentara
disolver también quiso intervenir el
poder judicial a la fiscalía y el
tribunal constitucional fue encarcelado
y su vicepresidenta Dina boluarte lo
reemplazó en el cargo y se convirtió en
la primera presidenta en la historia del
país pero también en la sexta persona en
ocupar el cargo En cinco años
en protestas contra boluarte brutalmente
reprimidas se ha desatado la peor ola de
violencia política de los últimos 20
años cómo llegó Perú a esta debacle
política por un lado una frágil
gobernanza de Pedro Castillo tuvo mucho
que ver desde que llegó al poder en
julio de 2021 a Pedro Castillo le fue
prácticamente imposible gobernar la
derecha intentó destituirlo en varias
ocasiones ya en campaña se había negado
a reconocerlo como mandatario
simpatizantes de Castillo reclaman que
fue el bloqueo institucional lo que le
prohibió ejecutar un plan de gobierno
pero sus detractores alegan que fue el
gobernante Quien no tuvo la capacidad
para brindar estabilidad ni una hoja de
ruta clara al país Castillo designó 5
gabinetes en año y medio esto aumentó
aún más la sensación de crisis entre los
ministros que nombró algunos son
investigados por violencia política
corrupción o incluso asesinato la
corrupción en la política nacional es el
factor clave Pedro Castillo fue acusado
de dirigir una organización criminal
para obtener beneficios de contratos
estatales él siempre negó estas
acusaciones y sus seguidores denunciaron
un esfuerzo de las élites políticas para
apartarlo del Poder y es que la vacancia
contra Castillo es tan solo el último
capítulo de una larguísima crisis fue el
más reciente presidente elegido en los
urnas Pero antes de esto Perú tampoco
gozaba de estabilidad política en 2018
el entonces presidente Pedro Pablo
kuczynski renunció Al cargo acusado de
sobornos y corrupción y a Martín
vizcarra su sucesor el congreso lo
destituyó en 2020 por señalamientos
similares también desfilaron por el
cargo Manuel Merino que gobernó durante
seis días en 2020 y Francisco sagasti
durante ocho meses las acusaciones de
corrupción en Presidencia han sido
notorios Alberto fujimori está
actualmente cumpliendo condena ollanta
humala fue sancionado con nueve meses de
prisión preventiva ku permaneció durante
años en arresto domiciliario Alejandro
Toledo podría ser extraditado y Alan
García se suicidó cuando era investigado
pero la corrupción también salpica al
congreso
los legisladores han sido reiteradamente
acusados de actuar tan solo bajo sus
propios intereses y de amenazar al
ejecutivo con frecuencia para obtener lo
que necesitan también keiko fujimori la
actual líder del partido fuerza Popular
dominante en el congreso desde 2016 es
investigada por los presuntos delitos de
lavado de activos organización criminal
y obstrucción a la justicia división
ejecutivo legislativo otro factor
determinante la sociedad peruana Aún
está marcada por la dictadura que vivió
el país de la mano de Alberto fujimori
lo que ha hecho que en las elecciones de
2011 2016 y 2021 ganarán las fuerzas
anti fujimoristas impulsadas por el voto
castigo pero siempre con una distancia
muy de keiko fujimori la división en las
urnas ha dejado también a los
presidentes sin un respaldo sólido en el
congreso donde fuerza popular y otros
partidos de derecha han dominado en los
últimos años por si fuera poco El
Ejecutivo y el legislativo cuentan con
armas para perjudicarse mutuamente
veamos por un lado el presidente puede
disolver al congreso si este rechaza dos
cuestiones de confianza a dos gabinetes
de un mismo gobierno y el legislativo
puede destituir o abar al presidente por
lo que se conoce como incapacidad moral
un término introducido en la
Constitución de 1839 en este tiene
cabida desde la muerte hasta la falta de
autoridad moral para ejercer el cargo
varios presidentes como vizcarra y
Castillo han sido vacados por
incapacidad moral no obstante la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos y muchos otros órganos han
recomendado revisar este concepto por su
ambigüedad Y es que además es muy fácil
aprobarlo tan solo se requiere el 20% de
los votos del congreso para pedirlo y el
66% para aprobarlo a esto se suma que en
Perú El Congreso es unicameral una de
las principales demandas de politólogos
y analistas políticos es la creación de
un senado que haga contrapeso a la única
cámara que existe en este momento por
último otro de los factores que más
señalan los analistas políticos en la
crisis actual es el hecho de que en Perú
no existe un sistema de partidos
políticos que dé respuesta a las
demandas ciudadanas con frecuencia los
políticos velan más por sus propios
intereses que por los de la ciudadanía
que los eligió lo que fomenta aún más la
corrupción de acuerdo a la más reciente
encuesta de ipsos El 82% de la población
desaprueba la gestión del Congreso un
récord en 20 años ahora miles de
simpatizantes el castillo piden la
división de boluarte el cierre del
Congreso cambios en la Constitución la
liberación del expresidente y elecciones
anticipadas elecciones que han sido
también propuestas por la misma boluarte
sin embargo la mandataria se niega a
renunciar al cargo a pesar de que ya son
decenas las personas muertas en medio de
una brutal represión de las
manifestaciones pero boluarte tampoco
está exenta de perder su mandato como la
mayoría de sus antecesores y que el
círculo vicioso vuelva a comenzar si le
sirvió el video para entender la crisis
política en Perú los esperamos en otro
episodio de en cinco minutos en France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]